Hurricane Maria could not have come at a
worse time for Puerto Rico's economy
again it is no secret that before the
hurricane when Rico faced very very
serious economic problems but Rico is
saddled with a debt of some 73 billion
dollars Puerto Rico's future depends on
many factors chief among them an exodus
of people who can no longer sustain
themselves a shortage of drinking water
food and shelter has driven thousands of
Puerto Ricans from their homes droves of
families are leaving the island for the
US mainland
experts estimate that nearly half a
million Puerto Ricans could leave the
island as a result of the storm about
14% of the population over 100,000 have
already fled and many of them are coming
here to New York which already has the
largest population of Puerto Ricans
outside the island itself one popular
destination is Spanish Harlem where the
Puerto Rican presence is visible led
most a Christian Church partnering with
Mayor Bill de Blasio's office is hosting
a Thanksgiving dinner for those who just
arrived from Puerto Rico families
filtering from various shelters in the
area
Oh a Seattle area tango passaglia por la
noche no bonemeal means on the way you
theater I mean I want to you Rondo we
met her Sally Fuentes who left with her
husband after their house was decimated
and food became scarce so attend a mucho
tiempo para que Porto Rico Sarah Cooper
a valgus incumbent
I bore a son una decisión a por la Kwan
fo say oh no Ben you know a fascist
island led to gente de algo de taco to
morado
yo hey mi familia yeah la familia me Oso
seguro Maya no Zakarian mean when Tess's
family is one of over 1300 to arrive in
New York since Maria for Denise and her
boyfriend Felix who didn't want to
appear on camera the situation is even
more dire the storm drove them from a
normal life in Puerto Rico into
homelessness in New York City we didn't
even know where we weren't gonna sleep
that night and it was very hard when we
got here we just looked around like well
when are we going so every night you
walk 20 floors up yes we penis when I
sleep in the zoo if we go to a shelter
first of all I don't have my social
security card yet and I needed to go
there having lost everything in Puerto
Rico Denis and Felix resorted to begging
for money in the streets of New York one
day I stayed on street and I saw her
asking about money and I'm so so bad
because I'm the best we have already the
people with industry and we're missing
the situation they are know sometimes we
have to ask for money to me
[Music]
for leaders in Puerto Rico keeping
families and particularly young workers
on the island is vital so what can party
Rico do to keep young talent on island
in the wake of this time the objective
is that we not only keep the young
talent that we keep the people here I
mean that people is still a a place that
can provide the quality of life and the
opportunities for everybody you know
whether you're young or whether you're
at whatever stage you are in your life
right now even though we may be
progressing and we still you know
managing the challenge there is an
expectation that there's gonna be a loss
in population when you look at the
models when you look some of these
forecasts there's gonna be a lot of
private investment that we expect as
part of the rebuilding and recovery
process there's gonna be a lot of money
from the federal government in the range
of the millions of dollars that is going
to be used for net recovery and the
rebuilding process just four months
before the storm puerto rico declared
bankruptcy the first american state or
territory to do so massive municipal
debt rendered the islands government
ineffective the culmination of a
decade-long recession when maria arrived
it wiped out the electrical grid an
infrastructure repair costs are
estimated at eighty billion dollars with
its financial issues compounded leaders
are desperate for federal resources to
save the economy and set it back on
track clearly the wall of the federal
government and our agencies is do
everything possible there will be a very
big debate in the Congress about what we
call a supplemental package disaster
relief which will include substantially
more money for Puerto Rico for Florida
for Texas and for the Virgin Islands and
that amount of money will be in the many
many billions of dollars so far Florida
is seeing the brunt of the exit
nearly 200,000 per torii can have
already settled there in New York City
leadership is making an effort to
support families who have recently
arrived Spanish colonists has a hitch
concentration in Puerto Rican so we knew
exactly that this is the best place to
open up the center what kind of things
do you do for new arrivals so you know
going to New York City is a huge city
and if you're new even if you have
family members sometimes you don't know
how to navigate or how to go to
different city agencies and the services
they provide the city is helping new
arrivals with things like housing
shelter health care and registering
children with the Department of
Education when you talk to people do
they want to stay in New York do they
want to be relocated are they planning
to go back to Puerto Rico the immediate
need will be making sure that they
follow up with the factors and make sure
that the health condition is okay a lot
of the people what they're worried about
is what is available to us now that we
can get whatever the cause be at the
economy or the storm an astonishing
number of families have left the island
it's individuals like Sebastian a Puerto
Rican chef and restaurant owner who are
left to pick up the pieces and see that
the island remains an attractive place
for both residents and tourists I'm
sticking around that was an easy
decision from the beginning I had to
close up the restaurant but the decision
of staying in the island that was there
was no way of that I was leaving
Sebastian's main challenge now is a
balance between reviving his business
and volunteering which he finds vital to
the recovery effort you never even
thought about the idea of going back to
the snow no I I came back five years ago
to open up my business and help the
local economy and I'm planning on
staying here and helping out so my
decision was close up work find work
part-time wherever I can doing some
volunteer work
for someone like sebastian how do you
keep hope alive
is there anything tangible you can do
beyond pushing the plan I mean in the
immediate aftermath we have to ensure
that we transmit the credibility to the
general public
that there is a leadership we need to
make sure that we give them the
confidence that we are addressing the
situation that we're doing everything we
can and that we making progress so
credibility is key local leaders like
secretary Rivera talk about credibility
and public perception but when it comes
down to it it's something much simpler
keeping people like sebastian from
leaving there's no doubt in my mind that
i'm sticking around
i came back a few years ago and i had it
as a mission to help yeah and i grew up
with its tom it's home it's it's what i
want to where i want to work what i want
to have my family grow up in and have
the same opportunities that I had
[Music]
hey it's Ahmed thanks for watching and
please don't forget to subscribe to aj+
for more on Puerto Rico as well as more
documentaries like this and be sure to
check out the rest of the series where
we explore the recovery efforts and we
also investigate the economic situation
in crisis on the island